let's talk about some of the news that's
sweeping the country all right
ladies and gentlemen donald trump
recently announced he's gonna be banning
critical race theory
from federal trainings and stuff and of
course the left-wing media came out and
we're like uh trump's making things up
it's a right-wing tempest it's not real
it is a very serious problem it does
exist and there are real examples
they just don't bother to google search
but i want to show you the story from
the atlantic
they write for the first time america
may have an anti-racist
majority not since reconstruction has
there been an
opportunity for the advancement of
racial justice
what does justice mean well what is
racial justice there's that meme where
the one guy has a bo they all have boxes
but one guy's tall and one guy's short
and
the short guy can't see over the fence
so you give the tall guys box to the
short guy
and then the short guy has two boxes but
then they can all see over the fence
what if the guy
what if the tall guy on his box liked
the breeze right then who's right is it
to take i think he gave it over his own
volition but that's the part
no no no is it just to say hey maybe you
like the breeze but he can't see and
it's more important than the way you
feel
so into it so we we have talked about
this image before
you you've got three people standing up
against the fence
and they're all standing on a box the
tall guy and the medium guy can see the
baseball game and the short guy can't
and so then what they do is they take as
you mentioned the box and the tall guy
give it a short guy and now they're all
standing there at equal level watching
the baseball game
one of my favorite responses to that is
they're stealing because they didn't pay
yeah but um actually my favorite
response is
they the fence is really high no one can
see anything with the tall guy
and then the tall guy has his legs cut
legs cut off and he's he's on stumps and
there's blood everywhere
and that's a better description of what
they're talking about and i'll explain
it to you
what is the societal equivalent of a box
money well you no it's it's you can't
quantify it
because they're talking about racial
privileges right they're not talking
about cash i don't know it's like who
can see the game whoever can afford to
buy the ticket
they're saying straight up that a
homeless white person is an oppressor
and a wealthy black woman is oppressed
money is not the factor the factor is
skin color and the ability to function
in society or something like that
okay in which case the only way to come
about with real equity
is to you know chop someone's legs off
if you're tall
we can't make short people tall but we
can make the one tall person short
get it and then they'll figure out a
different way to view the game together
because you've stripped then nobody can
see the game yeah unless they figure out
a way to
to build a portal to all watch it like
it's going to incentivize the tall guy
to figure out a way to get them to all
sorts of games
there's a bunch of memes one of them is
like the libertarian one is there's no
fence
and like that's good nothing matters and
there's there's one where it's like the
fence is a chain link fence so it
doesn't matter either
and that was like the engineer's
response or something like that there's
a bunch of funny answers to this it's
kind of dumb
but this is what i want to show you what
does it mean
to have an anti-racist majority in this
country what is the goal
welcome to twitter this is fj the real
racist
feminista jones who is this lady she is
nathan morris of boys two men gave me a
rose
i don't know what that means which is
173 500 followers
here's what she tweeted in the thread
over a week ago
and twitter allows this to remain on
on the platform that's interesting she
said begging white people to support
black lives matter and related work has
deluded the integrity of true
revolutionary work
i still don't get why folks were so
focused on getting mainstream support
when it only means the inevitable
destruction of the movement
white people no matter how liberal or
progressive will never endorse
revolutionary acts that many that that
may
jeopardize their children's lives and
that's true as such
they will never fully support a black
liberation revolution
by way of violent rebellion nope not not
going to happen
she goes on to say that violence is the
only way of course no votes no marching
no spots on cable news no high fashion
magazine cover stories no hashtags no
panels
none of that is going to bring about the
liberation black folks deserve
that's been up since august 27th
a call for violence it sounds like an
overt
violence because it's not a a a uh what
do they call it an
um a call it's not like let's go to
commit violence on this day at this time
it's not specific yeah yeah it has no
specific targets it doesn't violate the
terms at least that's what it is
so you have experience moderating stuff
yeah would you get rid of a post like
that no because it doesn't call for
um imminent violence that's where you
draw the line is if they're saying
at this time we're going to do this at
this time if they're saying get angry
blow stuff up it's just not imminent
violence not grounds for terms
i'll be honest you know i agree i hear
what you're saying and i'm actually glad
that she's posted it and it's allowed to
remain i'm glad to see it because now we
know
what at least some of these people are
thinking i mean this woman is
verified on twitter with 173 500
followers
saying gotta get violent all right is
that is that betsy
yeah she wants to join another this is
another thing you're joining us yeah
normally because normally ian's he's not
in the room so she's hanging out with
you
yeah so here's what she says she says
folks only understand violence and it's
eurocentric framing and definition
same as liberation if we're being honest
so you hear violence and you already
have a picture of what it looks
like and you've been conditioned to
reject it out of fear what if i told you
the violence required is liberating
what if i told you that there is no way
for a dislocated displaced african to
truly live free
without the complete destruction of
whiteness
occupation of space in our minds bodies
souls and communities you know what
whiteness means
no their definition hard work scheduling
time planning for the future okay that's
whiteness diligence
definitely definitely the crazy thing
about this is it's
it's not like they're they're african
cultures that have hard work and
time and schedules to say that yeah i
mean especially if if you go by
you know the out of africa theory and
they say that africa was the cradle of
humanity or whatever yeah i've heard
some people say that there's actually
evidence
humanity may have come from other places
or been in other places earlier the
point is
if the prevailing theory right now
suggests that humans started in africa
and succeeded greatly
then wouldn't it be hard work and
perseverance is a trait of blackness
it's a human trait it's i definitely
think it's a human trait it tends
towards survivability and success you
know
group community function um
and you need this is betsy's tail by the
way
yeah um after the great flood twelve
thousand eight hundred years ago you
know the commentary impact the great
flood from all that
humanity yeah according to like
geologists uh randall carlson
particularly though
that's very culture agrees on some kind
of great flight yeah nuclear glass in
the in the melt
water in the dirt at that time really
cool really cool evidence
no way i'd have to pull up facts to
really convince you i'm sure but yeah
probably yeah assuming that there was a
great flood humanity recollected in that
area so
i don't know if all humans came from the
cradle but it seems like that's where
society rebooted
and maybe i was i was reading that there
were like 10 humans
that like created all of humanity or
something whoa you know i like to
believe instead though that you know
it's it's actually like you see
battlestar galactica yeah how at the end
of the series they like they made it to
an earth-like planet oh yeah there you
go that's what really happened we just
it's battlestar galactica
we're we're on we're on season 2020 of
battle star
that's where we're at you think that
earth was seated by fungus
that panspermia we're gonna we're gonna
get just shot across the universe and
pelted all the oceans i don't know about
all that but i can say that it has
nothing to do
with it
i guess we do huh yeah violent violence
the
the rise of violence what they claim to
be is anti-racist when they're
specifically talking about people of a
certain race being violent to liberate
themselves to feel good about it it's
i think it's the problem is that you're
blaming any one species
or any one race even you know we're all
in this together as a human race we
function
better in a group regardless of our skin
or the way we look or
smell or sound or any of that i think
you're entirely correct and this is
something interesting this is an example
of a dangerous idea
and i think that should be she should be
free to say it obviously because i want
to know exactly what people are thinking
but
that doesn't mean it's less of a
dangerous idea and the fact that she is
free to say it
means that now other people might be
able to adopt what she's thinking and go
with it
it makes an argument for censorship and
like
is sometimes censorship valuable well
then you get into the question the
fundamental question underneath every
kind of censorship is who decides
and that's always the question and you
can say it's going to be a christian
conservative
not everyone's going to like that you
can say it's going to be an atheist and
the christians are going to be shut out
or you can say it's going to be somebody
like this lady
that's dangerous too because even groups
can go crazy right exactly or
or it might be some random wmixon oh
gosh yeah that's more likely
so i forget so i'm definitely gonna
we're definitely gonna talk about this
too in in this similar context
when the atlantic writes an article
which to be honest like we didn't
actually read it
so i'm not i'm not trying at the time
well no what i'm saying is
it is it's important to read all the
stuff i'm not presenting the criticism
in the context of what the argument from
the article is
i'm presenting in the context of the
ideas of anti-racism
and what we actually get is this insane
critical theory which encompasses so
many other things
so when donald trump says something like
you've drank the kool-aid
donald trump banned critical race theory
but what about critical gender theory
you know yeah there's everything what
about all of these different theories
which brings me to wmixon one of my
favorite words in the made-up
you know english language i'm sorry i'm
sure at some point it'll end up in the
dictionary because dictionary.com and
merriam-webster tend to be woke
so who owns those who decides that stuff
i was wondering that
a couple days ago no i'm gonna have to
look that up i don't know um
but that's weird that we like just let's
accept it and we don't know who
writes it that's crazy we're just
changing ten people
like think about this word okay you're
listening to me speak
what does whimxion mean if if you just
heard that word whimxen
what is that like a tennis like a tennis
and players
yeah yeah yeah yeah you can see that
outfit yeah it is just an
alternate spelling of the word woman
with an x
instead of an a or an e so it's
pronounced they say it's pronounced like
woman but come on let's be honest
if you showed that word to someone who
was learning english they would go
mexican and it's the x because the x y
chromosome it's pronounced like a y but
it's the x
okay
i understand so look at this ted london
why we're using wmixon
no that's not a typo whimxin is a
spelling of women that's
more inclusive and progressive the term
sheds lights on the prejudice
discrimination and
institutional barriers whimixin have
faced and explicitly includes
non-cisgendered women so what they're
basically saying is that the word woman
does not include trans women so they're
transphobic i see
so this is all women including trans
women which is transphobic because trans
women are women right
uh depends on who you ask but i think
yes yeah they are so among the left when
they say trans women are women the idea
that you would need to create a new word
wmixon
is transphobic because you're basically
saying that what
trans women do not are not defined by
the word women
right this is the inherent problem of
the
abs of the absurdity of this game they
play where
nothing can ever be not offensive
so here's what i said i said the end
goal of this stuff really is just to
break our society isn't it let's roll
with it okay
wimxin is actually racist because it's
still using the latin alphabet and
doesn't represent people of all cultures
yeah every letter we use is a racist
uh what do they call like a kudos to the
the the
slave masters of old the romans actually
yep there it is
so if they're going to say we're going
to change the e to an x
because that's inclusive well then i
would argue what about cyrillic
what about asian characters or thai or
indian you know
whatever we have another guest
so so here's here's what i i put i don't
think i can actually pronounce this
it's like i'm not gonna even bother
saying this i'm gonna end up saying
something really dumb in chinese if i
say hello
but uh you see i included these symbols
here
inside the word wimixon to create uh
a new word it's a beautiful word yeah
the chinese characters i put in there
just about communist
i'm sorry communism communism and
yes woman communism get out of here what
are you doing there's a cat on the table
what are they what
it's because you were here they love the
energy free for all now he's sitting on
the table
yeah he's chilling he's the centerpiece
he is the
so i have an issue with the word women
maybe you guys can help me out with sure
why is the word men
in the word women because the original
word
was whiffman and the original word for
male was
wearman so oh so is the wife of the man
wife that's where her wife comes from so
it was weirman
werman meaning male human and with men
female human
and eventually it became woman and
that's where werewolf comes from
where wolf was like human wolf right
interesting
so man was just a reference to humanity
i see
but eventually over time i guess because
of the patriarchy
man became to reference colloquially
human males
and and i say patriarchy but i actually
as as much as it is silly i do mean that
in a certain sense you so you know early
on when humans were a bit more tribal
and nomadic
and and i'm not going to tend to be an
anthropologist or sociologist to know
the finer details but i would just
surmise that uh there were specific
descriptors between the males and the
females were men with men
and that's my understanding it's like
i've got the book pulled up i can't tell
you everything specifically
did he just try and drink it he did try
to put his paw into your water oh come
on i watched it
and i couldn't say anything about it i'm
sorry i got a gate right here anyway
anyway i was talking about the root
words so not listening sorry
eventually when society was built uh
i've read you know this is really funny
we're going to get into these uh these
studies because
if i don't pull up the sources then
people try and claim it's not true
or whatever but anyway i was reading a
study that basically said
not a study but it was like a research
paper talking about the rise of
civilization and patriarchy
and what they basically said was because
women are so important and to society
that women were protected which
gradually evolved into traditional
gender roles of
the men would go out and work and the
woman would stay home where it was safe
now he's drinking your water bacon wants
a piece yeah so so so the idea was
in in early human civilization you have
men going on the hunt and stuff like
that women were you know gathering and
taking care of the
the tribe where men were taking more
risks but but because they were all
really much around
each other that they basically said we
had words to describe
you know different genders but once it
became to be that women were staying
behind and civilization was functioning
with men doing the work
then men only talking to each other
would just say man because it was
simpler among themselves or if they made
a reference to all people
it typically would only refer to human
beings like they would go out on hunting
missions for months at a time
the men as far as i know like ancient
native american cultures they'd go out
for like weeks at a time so they'd only
be with guys
yeah so i can see that the languages i
don't know a whole lot about
that stuff yeah it would be longer than
a day or two they go out for for long
periods of time also the the idea of
um patronage and like the patriarchy is
like
ancient venice for instance was a
patriarchy the the patron
or the the oldest male of the family or
the most prominent male would be in
charge of the entire
city and then when he died they would
vote for another patron
it's kind of like it's kind of like um
um
uh wakanda you know where where the
black panther and
t'challa and all that stuff because they
had uh kind of except that
uh ritual combat to determine the king
oh wow yeah it was it was a patriarchal
monarchist
ritual combat government whoa
please i love how that was like a
popular movie they were like yeah
i mean you know chadwick boseman was an
awesome awesome dude so you know
rest in peace i'm sad to hear you know
something i've seen wakanda mana or uh
like black panther i hear it's awesome
i'd give it a seven out of ten like
marvel movies tend to be good
but a lot of people were acting like it
was some grand masterpiece for like you
know racial reasons and stuff like that
and i'm like
you know if people if my response to a
lot of the stuff is
people have their opinions and their
views and i don't i really don't care if
someone comes out and they were like
this is what it meant to me i'm like
that's really cool oh yeah
you know you do your thing i'm not going
to move those are your feelings i'm not
gonna i'm not gonna argue about how you
feel yeah i would judge
since i studied it i judge it more like
critical critically a funny word to
throw around these days but like more
like
what's the plot how do the scenes how's
the lighting in the scene like that's
how i get yeah
not how i emotionally yeah some of the
cgi was kind of
at the end it turns me off yeah like the
final fight scene thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you